inside Justin and Selena's reunion at
her house and we're also taking you guys
to the world series entertainment
tonight at the world series baby yay yay
happy hump day my friends i am danny
direct oh and just one day after
reuniting with her old pal Demi Lovato
Selena Gomez and Justin Bieber are
hanging out her house new photos have
surfaced that's got us all wondering is
Jelena getting back together et has
learned it is a fact the two reunited
Sunday at Selena's home
Justin arrived first followed 10 minutes
later by a casually dressed Selena but
hate to break it to you guys a source
tells us it is pure fiction
that the meeting was romantic Selena is
still committed to her boyfriend the
weekend who is currently on tour still
there is nothing like showing up at your
former girlfriends house to fuel those
rumors so what's really going on a
source tells us Selena was hosting
friends from Hillsong Church they say
quote Selena is the one who got Justin
involved in this church so they have a
lot of mutual friends now from that our
source also says Selena is making amends
with fractured relationships from the
past
after she underwent that life-saving
kidney transplant in the summer and
today Selena released her new single
wolves and in an Apple music interview
she said the song reflects what she was
going through during that time in Japan
you'll remember after Selena's Tokyo
concert in August 2016 she canceled the
rest of the tour due to anxiety and
depression due to her lupus well things
seem to be looking up for her but also
for the Biebs to another source told ET
quote Justin wants to be a good friend
to her at least for now it's a
friendship at least for now what do you
guys think can exes just be friends more
importantly congestion and Selena just
be friends let me know but we are
switching gears now because it is an
exciting time to be in Los Angeles the
Dodgers are in the World Series which
means I now care about baseball
no for real my parents took my sisters
and I to all the games as kids they lost
every time plus the last time the
Dodgers were in the World Series was
1988 so this is a big deal and of course
Hollywood turned out to witness
yesterday's victory including Lady gaga
and what I can only describe as
appropriate baseball attire right
well tonight is Game two and joining us
now from Dodger Stadium is friend of the
show ash cross in ash you are in the
center of the madness what's it like
down there today yeah Danny I got to be
totally honest with you I'm not even
wearing a headset but it is a hundred
and two degrees here at the 2017 World
Series the first one for the Dodgers in
nearly 30 years but you know what I had
no idea I'm talking about you know who
does your daily Denny producer the guy
behind the camera right now Ricardo at
chellah I'm gonna bring him in I'm gonna
bring him in front of the camera for one
there you go this is deserve to shine oh
my gosh it's too hot
Ricardo how you feeling right now pretty
hot this is amazing I don't know how I
feel I'm just like beyond words right
now you're on the field right now you
are a die-hard Dodger fan
we're at the World Series yes sum it up
in one word so much blue
I saw Vince Kelley's press box I'm
beyond myself I can't even like hold it
in being here is just an honor and
thought because of You Man
102 degrees outside solo hot here but
I've got the coolest seat in the house
the best seat in the house because I'm
in the Dodgers dugout yeah this is the
hottest ticket in town this stadium is
found to be riddled with celebs we're
gonna try to talk to as many as we
possibly can
let's play ball
[Music]
we're back after 29 years it's about
time you know right will we belong so
let's just do it you know it's time to
just put four games together and win
this thing so it's about time I'm very
excited and I get you soon as a great
team it's gonna be a great series
all right 96 year old father's here and
my 8 year old son's here so it's three
generations I was here 29 years ago
World Series Game one for Kirk Gibson's
historic shot so we'll see what we have
tonight how you doing good okay he's
watching everybody he's so excited yes
oh my god we are losing it in this
studio if you guys only knew what a huge
Dodgers fan Ricciardo is I mean what an
assignment special thanks to ask for
making Ricardo's wildest dreams come
true and if you liked what you saw then
prove it and give this bit a thumbs up
and holler at me in the comment section
and I'll see you guys tomorrow
[Music]